ام قيس المدينه الاثريه التي اطلق عليها
المؤرخون اسم اثينا الشرق بعدما استوطنها
اليونان منذ 400 عام قبل الميلاد
تضم المدينه الواقعه شمالي الاردن في
جنباتها شواهد اثريه وسياحيه متعدده
الحضارات منذ عهد اليونان والرومان والعهد
الاسلامي فضلا عن كونها ثاني مدينه
رومانيه في الاردن احتفظت بمعظم اثارها
بعد مدينه جرش الاثريه واقع اهلها لتكون
ضمن تصنيف منظمه السياحه العالميه للقرى
العالميه
وهي حضاره استيطان وليست حضاره عبور انا
اقول لكل من يريد ان يعلم اولاد تاريخه
عليكم بام قيس مكان في مناظر طبيعيه
وجميله جدا بتذكرني بلبنان
وعرفت عن المكان من المشاهير السوشيال
ميديا
تجاور المدينه الاثريه ام قيس قريتها
الوادعه التي يامل سكانها انتعاشا ينتشلها
من ضعف بنيتها التحتيه وجيوب الفقر داخلها
يقول الاهالي هنا ان سلطات السياحه اهملت
المدينه السياحيه وفشلت في جذب استثمارات
تزيد اعداد السياح
كل الجهات الان معنيه بتطوير موقع ام قيس
الاثري توفير البنيه التحتيه موقعها
الاثري موقعها التراثي موقعها الطبيعي
يعني يعطيها دور لان يقيم بها ويقضي ليله
كامله
وعلى مرمى البصر تجمع مقيس بلاد الشام في
بقعه واحده فجبال الجولان السوريه وبحيره
طبريه في فلسطين المحتله وملامح جبل الشيخ
تحيط بها من كل جانب
انفاقها المائيه تمتد لعشرات الكيلومترات
تحت الارض وتقع على طريق مئات الينابيع
ونهري الاردن واليرموك وبحيره طبريا
ثراء اثري يامل خبراء السياحه في الاردن
ان يكون رافعا لترويج ام قيس كواحده من
افضل القرى السياحيه في العالم عبر مرافق
وخدمات جاذبه رائد عواد الجزيره ام قيس
شماليه الاردن